in this video we're going to talk about
an idea that's crucial to the proper
functioning of an economy under a
market-based system and that's the idea
of property rights and it's just the
idea that everyone agrees on who owns
what and what can they do with that
property and for many of us who live in
a part of the world with strong property
rights we take all of that for granted
we know who owns that house and what
they have the right to do with that
house and if they were to sell that
house how that would occur but in some
parts of the world or in some parts of
history that wasn't so clear someone
might say they own the house but then
another person might live in that house
and they say well i've been living here
for 10 years it's my house now deal with
it or they might go hire some thugs to
say hey owner sell me the house for less
than you then then the market value
otherwise we're going to hurt you in
some way and so in some ways they're
infringing on those property rights or
the government might just come in and
say we're going to take that property
from you because we want it in those
situations property rights would be
weakened and what we're going to do is a
little bit of a thought experiment to
see why it's so crucial for the proper
functioning of a market economy
so let's stick with the house analogy so
let's say that we have some blue houses
in our in our economy that look like
that let's say it's owned by this person
right over here
let's say we have some pink houses that
look like that let's say it's owned by
that person right over there and let's
say that we have some orange houses that
look something like that they have some
kind of arch at the top and let's say
it's owned by something like this
and let's say these people are all
interested in selling their house maybe
they're downsizing or they're retiring
or they're moving someplace else and so
there's a market of potential buyers so
let me draw
the
buyers right over here
and so there might be some people and if
we have properly functioning property
rights there might be some people who
are really interested in the blue house
and so whoever is willing to pay the
most for that blue house will get it and
so let's say that this person is willing
to pay i'll just say one dollar sign
for the house and so the the ownership
of the house will go to that person
same thing for the pink houses maybe
this person right over here is the
person who really likes the pink houses
they pay a different price maybe a
little bit more i'll do two dollar signs
to represent that and then they will get
title to the house
and maybe a ton of people are really
interested in these arched houses and
maybe they bid for it and the bidding
keeps going higher and higher and higher
this person wins at the end and they
have to pay up a lot
for
that orange house and then they get
title for it
and let's just assume that for whatever
reason that they're all about the same
cost to build well what would happen in
this market then well home builders or
or even people who own other types of
houses will say wow i can get a lot more
for the orange house the market is
giving us a price signal so this right
over here this is a price signal in fact
they're all price signals that and when
you take them together you're saying hey
i get more for an orange house than a
blue house and so maybe if they all cost
the same to build we'll start producing
more of these orange houses so the
builders will produce more of these
orange houses and maybe some people
might remodel their blue houses to have
these orange arches on them and so you
could imagine that might happen from
that price signal because it's clear
that that's where users preferences are
that's where the demand is
but now let's
imagine a slightly more dystopian world
and this actually is what much of human
history was and even some significant
parts of the world today
where there aren't clear property rights
when this person says they want to that
they have this house for sale these
people are like is it really your house
and then this person comes along says no
it's my house and i have this proof that
my grandfather owned it and he never
sold it to your grandfather and then
this person says um i have a lot of guns
and i don't care what you all say and
what paperwork you have but i'm taking
the house well how much would this
person be willing to pay this person
right over here in that circumstance and
so this person is much less likely to
get these three dollar signs this person
said hey this is kind of a risky
investment i don't really know if i take
title from this person whether it's
still my house so they're not willing to
give three dollar signs they're only
willing to give one dollar sign or maybe
no dollar signs maybe this house doesn't
even sell well then the price signals
have broken down and so then in this
market people will say oh maybe we'll
build more of the the arched orange
houses because that's what the market
demands and so you can quickly see that
when property rights break down
the market system breaks down because
the market system is all about people
using a price to figure out how much
they're willing to pay for things but
that assumes that when you get something
that it's really yours that it's not
going to be disputed and the person
you're buying from really has ownership
and this breakdown would often be
characterized as a market failure now
you could say okay there's other types
of systems that we talked about in other
videos we talk about command economies
and in the extreme in a command economy
you have no profit you have no private
ownership of things and so you might say
maybe that is a solution to this
property rights problem but command
economies have significant problems of
their own in fact very few of them or
really none of them in history have
proven to really work because they have
a major incentive problem because if
you're just being told what to build by
the government you're told how to build
it by the government you're told who to
gets it by the government there's very
little incentive to try to innovate to
try to build more to invest or whatever
else and we talk about that in other
videos so i will let you go there this
is just the introduction to think about
this idea of property rights and ask
your parents or talk around or if you
are a parent look at the world of how
much infrastructure we have in a society
like the united states or in much of the
world today to enforce property rights